here is Oscar nominee for Supporting
Actress in the English Patient Juliette
Binoche
forgive me but I don't remember whose
first set clothes make the man it was
from he said when we made made the
clothes back when men wore the pants and
women the dresses today when a man gets
in drag it's hilarious but when a woman
gets in drag is her money but whether a
man or a woman all I just know how
important it is for water to reflect the
characters we play many of us have worn
everything from auto Couture to fret
about a overcoats undergarments and
there have been some memorable moments
when we were nothing at all the
indispensable talents of our custom
designers are what we must rely on to
bring our characters to life here are
the nominees for best custom design for
angels and insects nominee Paul Brown
designed the unique and inventive
costumes of the period
for Emma nominee Ruth Meyers dress the
Victorians to depict the romance and
style of that wealthy Society
you
for the English Patient Nami and Roth
put her cast in khakis Cotton's and
leather and gave them scarves to protect
their faces during sandstorms
or Hamlet nominee Alex burn brought
original designs to rich picturesque
life
for the portrait of a lady nominee Janet
Patterson's dresses are conservative
high colored long sleeves and in the
elegant fabrics of that period
and the Oscar goes to and Rob English
Patient
thank you ladies and gentlemen thank you
Michael and dachi and Saul and Anthony
I'd like to use my 30 seconds to say
that my crew was from Italy Tunisia and
the United States but we're all
costumers and costumers no one language
and work beyond maps and boundaries
thank you